hey everybody and welcome to wild ride
with stevo
on this week's show i admit to being
very disrespectful
to the guest many years ago his name is
violent jay and you might know him from
the insane clown posse
and i'll tell you what's insane this
episode so strap on your seat belts
and enjoy ladies and gentlemen
violent jay [ __ ] yeah dude
all right now brother when's the last
time
we we saw each other in person like 2004
maybe that's what i was thinking yeah
2004 right
i met you at the hotel right i want to
say it was in orlando
and yeah we were performing at the house
with blues
and you were there you were there for
your own show but we met up at the hotel
you came to my show and i was
legitimately
an absolute [ __ ] uh zero
zero question about that and um you know
it completely
for all these years uh slipped my mind
that that's something that it was worth
addressing man and
so there i didn't do [ __ ] about it
and then not too long ago uh
i got a couple people send me this video
and it's uh
it's called violent j talks about his
beef with stevo
and i knew right away dude i i knew
right away and uh you know
i i don't know if we need to to probably
why don't we uh
you know go ahead and and i'll let you
have the floor tell my story yeah
tell your story a little bit i mean
anybody can go uh anybody can go check
out that video but if you can give him
the gist of it
and what year was this i think it was
2004. and i'm scott by the way
oh yeah sorry this is my co-host scott
ryan what's up dude
hey brother up front we got paul briskey
what's up man nice to meet you
you too bro um yeah it was it was like
um we were um staying at the hotel we're
we're just walking down the hallway
of the hotel and uh we see stevo walking
with another dude but i reckon i see one
i said hey man what's up brother
and he said what's up and i and i told
him who we were and what we were doing
in town and everything and um
he was mad cool at the beginning you
know what i'm saying
and um and you told us that um you told
us
you were you were getting ready to go uh
to your show
and we didn't have a show that night and
and uh we were there like
the next night i think we're that we had
a day off so we were like hell yeah
and you invited us to the show and it
was me and my uh
friend abk anybody killer and we were
like hell yeah
so we went first we went back to your
hotel room
and um we were hanging out and we
started talking you were like
you were like um man i went to clown
college i know all about being a climber
and you guys
ain't real clowns with man i don't know
what the [ __ ] you guys are man but you
guys ain't clowns you know
and that's not offensive because we're
not clowns you know what i mean dude
i i do remember that i
do remember that and like what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know
no no no that's not offensive i mean you
mean dude
of being clowns we're our own kind of
clowns you know what i mean i i i was
absolutely disrespectful and i think
that
i don't know if i if i made this
distinction but
uh what what's what's like odd to me
is that uh when you put on grease paint
it seems like you don't powder the
grease paint because
grease paint as like the way that i i do
it or the you know normal clowns
grease paint smears all over the place
you know but
when you take but we take baby powder we
put it in a sock
yeah you hit the sock and the baby
powder kind of makes a cloud yeah we do
that
sort of and it locks it locks the grease
paint in place
to the point where you can like dive
into a pool like swim through you know
like
that shit's locked it seems like you
don't powder yours
so if anything sometimes we we do
sometimes if it's a photo shoot or
something we'll we'll put the powder on
it to take the glare off it or the or
the look of uh
sweat or whatever you know right and if
anything touches it when it's not
powdered it's gonna smear it like crazy
like ah
yeah and i couldn't yeah and you pointed
that out you you pointed that
out i know you told me in 2004
right back it's more of an interesting
thing
and i i just was a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
cokehead you know were like doing coke
in the room
and they were there i'm sure i was you
know yeah you were doing something
i don't know what it was but it it it
wasn't a big deal you know what i mean
but um
you kept it was it was all cool and
everything but you kept slipping in
like jabs you know what i mean like like
we didn't know if we
we didn't know if we were welcome or not
because you kept everything you were
saying you were slipping jabs in in
distance here and there you know what i
mean but you wouldn't put them politely
you know what i mean you'd be like
oh yeah you guys are [ __ ] stupid
though the way you're playing your face
he's wrong with somebody you had camera
guys with you filming everything you
know
you're busting on us pretty hard with
the cameras on us you know what i mean
and um it was cool first couple times
but it became
like a thing you know and then um we
ended up going to the show
and man i never saw no [ __ ] like that in
my life man
like what well no here's like he made
this point in the video
that it was like stevo's got guys hey
who wants to see it kicked in the nuts
[ __ ] guys are like yeah it could have
so [ __ ] i'd get people on stage i
kick them in the nuts
and nobody kicks me in the nuts i'm just
doling out nut kicks
and then i'm like these [ __ ]
were killing themselves on stage
you'd be like all right matt you have
the dj up on stage and you're like
all right um who wants to get kicked in
the balls and everybody be like
the whole place is like yeah you know
and you bring like uh
five guys up on stage and tell them how
to spread their legs and they'd be lined
up along the line
with their legs spread and then you pull
a girl up on stage and you say
i want you to run up and kick them
[ __ ] smacking the ball as hard as you
can
are you ready and then she'd say yeah
you'd say don't
don't you know don't delay it and you
know
you guys want them to kick you hard
right and the guys will be like [ __ ]
yeah
and she would run up and put him in the
balls and the dj would
play the music you know and the music
would just amp everything up and she'd
be kicking him in the [ __ ] ball
i never saw those [ __ ] like that right
and then i got and then i got
like who are dude we're gonna have the
[ __ ] black eye game
you guys come up on stage and and uh
when i say go
start punching yourself in the face
trying to give yourself a black eye
or like first one to bleed wins
because everybody's thinking killing
themselves with the punching in the face
though that's what
that's the one that you really like
would turn themselves into like the
[ __ ] elephant man [ __ ]
like [ __ ] this one the bleed wins
nothing
you're right and uh and then you had an
after party in in the um you know
how the uh house of blues got those
sweet sweet-ass dressing rooms
big-ass uh dressing right and you had
like you had the whole thing turned out
it's a big-ass after party everybody was
up there
and um there was a kid sitting on a
counter and uh he looked just like the
elephant man bleeding
out of five places eyes all swelled up
lips [ __ ] cut up and i mean he was
[ __ ] up
like a train wreck and um he was sitting
there drinking a beer
and i was like man are you happy are you
happy you went up there
and he was like best night of my life
[ __ ] oh my god dude yeah now the only
and and all of that is absolutely
[ __ ] accurate and
the only thing i can say in my defense
about the nut kicking
and it's not even a defense is that when
i got sober
one of the first [ __ ] things i did
coming out of rehab
was i was like man that was wrong that i
traveled all the world
the black guy game with the guys
punching themselves wasn't very often
there was like uh
everything was like we didn't do that
much but the nut kicking i did that all
over the world
i did that all over the world and i
never let anybody kick me in the nuts
and i was like man that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
wrong so i went to
my buddy johnny knoxville i was like i
need i need you to [ __ ] really
[ __ ] kick me hard and i was butt
naked
you know that was like my first like
making an amends
you know like so i i knew that that was
[ __ ] up i knew that was wrong and that
was one of the first things i addressed
like when i got sober and uh and again
i was a complete [ __ ] to you i remember
and what was even worse
was that when you were at the show like
you didn't have your makeup on
yeah right and i was like i was like the
insane clown posse's over
here and [ __ ] make some noise for
them they're gonna come out on stage and
you were like yo dude we don't [ __ ]
come out on stage when we don't have our
makeup on like no
and i was like so then i start talking
about [ __ ] come on
these [ __ ] guys are [ __ ] [ __ ]
they won't come out man [ __ ] that
something like that and i think i if i
remember right you gave me
like a [ __ ] pretty dope icp jersey
that i was wearing i think you know like
and i was just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then anybody killers changed his
name to stevo killer at this point dude
like what the [ __ ]
you know at the time it was exciting
because we were seeing something we
never saw you know and
it's always cool to experience something
but there was so many like
disses throughout the night that it
didn't really honestly i'll be honest
man like we've been fans i've been a fan
forever you know and and um out of
watching all the jackass stuff you were
always my favorite one you know what i
mean for real you know
he's always seen the most charismatic
you know and um
and so it didn't really sink in until
the next day and then days after that
when i was telling a story to my friends
man yeah we went and hung out with steve
oh man he was addicted to us though but
it was cool man
i mean it was right kind of cool i was i
was disrespectful as [ __ ] man
and uh i wish i would have thought to
reach out to you
without all those years going by and
then seeing you
like uh telling the story on a youtube
video and then i thought man i gotta
[ __ ] get a hold of this guy you know
uh yeah yeah and you know what man i
read i read your book
i read your book when it came out and
and i was like that's the [ __ ] man
like i read about everything you went
through everything you've gone through
how you cleaned yourself
up and i've been following you since
then and i'm like [ __ ] yeah man that's
the [ __ ] man
and i see you now and i see who you are
now and man it's really the [ __ ] brother
it is it is very inspiring and very
[ __ ] dope man
um i appreciate that so much man any
type of ill will
that i had from that is long gone it was
gone after i read the book honestly
because i didn't understand all this i
didn't know all that about you you know
what i mean
and when i read the book i was like damn
man in in any ill will i had was long
gone after that man
and uh it's just it's just the [ __ ] that
man to watch you
what you doing now and all the things
you got going on now and everything man
and how you how you're kicking ass man
and and it's very inspiring man it's
really cool brother
i appreciate that i really really truly
do
and you know i also want to say that
when when you told that story on that
video that
the people were sending me like you told
it with
like humility like you weren't out to
[ __ ]
you know like it was it was completely
fair
the only thing that i took exception to
and
and and you know i i get it but but you
said
this guy had kicking people in the balls
he was [ __ ] up and he didn't do [ __ ]
and uh while i didn't let anybody kick
me in the balls i did make sure that i
was covered in my own blood every show
[ __ ] set myself on fire real good
like staple my ball sack to my leg like
all that i remember that show we
brought a [ __ ] like 12 foot long king
cobra
and we've released it on the stage
there's a little bit more to the show
than just [ __ ] up audience members oh
man i'm sorry bro
i don't expect it she would i don't
expect that you would and dude the last
[ __ ]
that's like saying hey man i'm really
sorry but so [ __ ] this
what a shitty [ __ ] uh way to approach
it and man like all these years gone by
and uh it's just this this means a lot
man this is this is uh
really cool to be able to have this
conversation with you and
yeah yeah i told that story we had a um
we did a uh um uh we've been doing this
every other month we've been doing a
stream uh a stream thing
where we stream live um every three
times
a week and we do something different
every time and that that
particular time i told the story was
when we were doing um
uh i can't remember what it was called
it's like campfire stories or something
yeah fireside chat kind of deal yeah
yeah we had like a
bonfire going a little stage setup and
um and
yeah and so that's what that was and
that was just in december last december
we i told that story you know
yeah but there's more there's more to
that story right because then you
you saw him again at the rainbow room
afternoon then
like after a little time went by then
you decided you know what next time we
see stevo we gotta [ __ ] beat his ass
yeah you heard that right they made an
actual plan to beat my ass
and you know if they did that to me
today they would find my ass
clean as a whistle because down here in
our new warehouse
i have outfitted the toilet with my
favorite
product that i have ever promoted on
this podcast
it is called hello tushy it's this
bidet that you easily set up to your
toilet
and when you get done taking a heavy
dump or any dump for that matter
you just twist the knob and
it blasts your [ __ ] so perfect man
right on the right spot and it's like
pressure cleaning all that poop off of
there
i mean think about it if you had poop
all over you
would you wipe it with paper towel or
would you get in the shower
come on man it's my favorite product
period it is such a joy for me to let
you know about it you have to get one
so here's how you do you go to
hellotushy.com
stevo why because by using that you're
going to get 10
off your order and free shipping
one more time to get 10 off your order
and free shipping
you're gonna go to hellotushy.com
stevo and trust me is gonna be the best
move you ever made
for your butthole because we we were
wild too
you know what i mean we we we were
younger a while too and we were like man
it started to really bother me and
everything after we left you know what i
mean
i was like man i feel i felt like a
trump were taken so much because it was
just me and
uh abk and and you and you had all your
dudes everywhere
filming everything and everything and i
was like man i felt outnumbered and
everything
and i was like man when i see him again
i'm gonna bring let's let's let's
you know let's kick a second and that's
not unusual for you right like you guys
like you know beefing with everybody
getting in fights like
that wouldn't have been out of like out
of the ordinary for you to actually oh
yeah
back then yeah it was it was it was it
was it was more of the regular thing for
us to be
you know uh you know we we don't
normally
instigate the attack we didn't normally
instigate fights so i
will say that but um i i just we just
got
i just got salty about man i thought for
sure
i thought for sure was going to come out
on one of your videos you know what i
mean
and i thought man i'm going to look like
a fully because i kept telling the guys
don't film me man try not to film me
with the with the i know
you know and the guys kept filming me
they didn't give a [ __ ] what i was
saying you know
and so i i thought man that shit's gonna
come out and so um
we ended up seeing you probably
probably no actually we saw you one
another time
and we didn't do nothing that time then
we said man next time we see him
but we didn't talk to you we just saw
you you know yeah and and we said i said
me and my guys we said next time we see
them we're gonna rough them up man
and um so we saw you at the rainbow room
sitting out on the out of the um uh
patio area
having this under water we were like
he's out there man let's go get him
so we mobbed up there you know what i'm
saying and we're like we're just gonna
run up on them and start socking them up
and um
saw you would be real you know we were
like oh [ __ ] that's the homie we can't
you know he's gonna be real that's a
that's a pass right there man we ain't
doing it gonna do [ __ ] throwing
real you know it's so we just were like
[ __ ] let it go
but then you know then i read the book
and everything and everything was
totally different after that you know
what i mean but but um
yeah you know um yeah we were well we
were wild too you know what i mean
and that's that's what it what
eventually became in our heads man we're
like man [ __ ]
that was wrong you know and um and we
that's how that's the level it built to
us you know
but um i'm glad nothing ever happened
man part of me wishes it did man that
part of me wishes that like
it would have turned into like a wu-tang
clan situation where
[ __ ] rayquan like had me by the neck
and he's like you're gonna apologize i'm
gonna knock you out from all these
people and i'm like
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry you should
have put on your clown makeup stephen
you're like let's do this
i mean i mean but whatever man it's just
it's really cool
to you know to to address that man and
you know what i remember and i'm sure i
never said this back in the day but
as i understood you and your career
you guys were on another on another
level
as far as owning your own [ __ ] as far as
your merchandise operation
like you guys had carved out your own
thing where you weren't the biggest band
but you had the most [ __ ] rabid
passionate
fan base that bought everything and you
guys were just
killing it as businessmen and uh
i don't know what what what we did to be
so fortunate to have
that kind of following man i i to this
day i don't know why
we're so blessed why we're so fortunate
to have
um uh people buy our music to support us
that hard man but they do and
they're the most wonderful most
outgoing like we we might not have
millions and millions of fans
but the the the people that support us
are strong
and they're they're loud like millions
and millions of fans you know what i
mean
and uh they're just incredible people
man they're they're they're very
creative and they're very um they don't
they don't walk with the sheep you know
they go their own route and everything
and they do their own thing
and uh they're the most amazing people i
know of and it's funny because
the reputation they have of being like
dangerous crazy insane people it's
it couldn't be any more opposite of the
truth
when you see the reputation they have
they don't just have a reputation for
being that
they're actually [ __ ] classified by
the fbi
as like a full-on [ __ ] gang
like like gang of in and gang
affiliation if you get labeled with that
that's like some heavy [ __ ] right it's a
pretty like what does that even mean
[ __ ] man it means a a number of things
depending on where you live
but like if you're let's say you're
having a um a custody battle
you know with with your ex your spouse
you know
their their attorney can say your honor
this person according to the
government is a gang member you know and
you could lose
you could lose your child you know for
something like that you know
and it's true if you're a juggalo in in
many in many areas
you're considered a gang member you know
as far as i know there's never been
anything like that in music that i've
ever heard of
you know where they took an entire fan
base and and
officially labeled them a gang you know
and the reason they do that a book came
out about it in
what according to the book the reason
they do that is because if you go to
like a
a rural area like these towns where
there's um
hardly anybody lives and it's way out in
the country or whatever
um and you got 50 kids at a
at a local park having a barbecue and
all those kids are wearing the same [ __ ]
and they all got the same logo on you
could say that's a gang
and if the police can say that's a gang
they get
government funding to to fight that gang
or
however that works you know what i mean
they get extra money to combat that gang
you know
so you have all these rule police forces
saying yeah we got that gang here too
you know
it's not really a gang of course but
it's the easy way for the cops
cops to make extra money for [ __ ]
take the dents out of their police
cruisers or something i don't know
you know that's crazy but it's crazy
[ __ ] insane man we
we didn't know what to do i mean are you
the gang leader technically
master in chief i mean i don't know what
i am to the fbi man i don't know what we
are today number one
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] insane and um
we didn't know what to do i mean what do
you do a situation like that we tried to
sue the fbi
uh it got thrown out of court four times
you know we try to assume we're like
this is [ __ ] insane man
like um you might even be getting
sentenced because you have some pot on
you or something
and you're being sentenced as a gang
member you know what i mean that's
what that like aggravates the yeah man
it
adds to your [ __ ] uh punishment you
know in
certain places and um [ __ ] is [ __ ] up
man
and you know like this one girl this one
thing always sticks out in my mind
she was um a probation officer
for 15 years this woman was a probation
officer
and on her walking papers i mean on the
[ __ ]
pink slip they gave her or whatever it
said right on there because
you're a juggalo you know they're they
fighter
15 years you know damn what's the
threshold
like what what uh qualifies one
officially as a juggalo spoiler alert
folks
i am totally planning on qualifying as a
member of their gang
and you know what else i think i already
qualify as
a hardcore athlete why because i wear a
whoop strap on my right wrist and i stay
on top of all the information that i get
from my whoop
app right what kind of information do i
get
well i know everything about the levels
of sleep
that i that i have right my deep sleep
my
rem sleep i know how much my body
recovers from the day before
i know how much strain i'm ready to take
on and when i do take on strain
i know exactly what's going on with my
heart rate my heart rate variability
i get more awesome information from my
whoop app than
i could get from any other fitness
tracker that's all there is to it
and you know what's going to happen
today right here in tight box packing
a little skate sesh yeah i'm going to
get a workout in
and it's going to be totally intense so
i want you guys to try this
how are you going to do it you're going
to go to woop.com
that's w-h-o-o-p-com
and you're going gonna use the promo
code stevo and that's gonna get you
15 off at checkout give it a shot man
become a hardcore athlete like myself
yeah
and now let's talk about gangs tattoos
or um you know like uh we're
having the sticker like that used to be
the thing to do to have a sticker
in your car you know with the with the
with the logo the hatchet man
in the back window it was way juggalos
identified each other
with this in the back window or whatever
but now nobody wants that in their back
window because they're the first to get
pulled over and [ __ ] with you know what
i mean
just for having it it's like a grateful
dead dancing bear
dude you know what i want to do i was
already thinking about it we were
checking it out the [ __ ]
hatchet man i want to join the gang dude
i want to [ __ ] yeah i feel like i i
feel like that would like
be cool for me to like heal from
from like the the you know this this
wreckage of my past
this this wrong that i did i feel like
if i got the [ __ ] hatchet man tattoo
like like are you down with me getting
the hatchet man tattoo dude is that
is that yeah brother i'm done with that
man
where did that come from the hatchet man
tattoo and that that symbol
it started off as a as a logo for our
record company
uh psychopathic records but i think it's
become more of a um
just the most recognized uh
juggalo logo i think you know that that
the juggalos used to identify each other
with like you might see that
tattooed on somebody and you and you
know they might
maybe you're maybe you're a waiter at a
restaurant or something
and you see that tattooed on some people
you're serving you know to give them a
break you know what i mean on their bill
or whatever you know what's inside club
a thing of love you know okay you got
something in common
something strong in common you know and
i think that's
that's where people were mistaken see
in the early days people used to come to
our concerts
at three o'clock in the afternoon you
know they'd be lined up there'd be 300
kids out there lined up
right and they say man you guys are
really popular they're all out there
lined up already and the doors don't
open until seven o'clock or whatever
but it wasn't for icp they were coming
they were they were lining up because
they love to be with each other they
love to
they you know you might feel like you're
you're
alone in this world you might feel like
you got nothing in common with nobody
and um but then when you would go to the
concert you would realize
man all these people are just like you
they find the same [ __ ] funny
they find the same [ __ ] touching they
find the same [ __ ] you know
you know what whatever it is you know
about you
you realize you're not alone you got all
these other people just like you
and you would people would recognize
that at our concerts
and it was never once that our
conscience wasn't some [ __ ] like
hey man you step on my shoe [ __ ]
you know what i mean
you don't see fights at our show man you
never ever see fights in our show
unless it's security or something
fighting
with with the juggalos you know juggalos
don't fight with each other man they
don't
never ever ever ever fight with each
other it just don't happen
and um people would come to the concerts
early
not because they they're so passionate
about icb
that's what it looked like but in
reality they were coming to be with each
other man
they loved it to to be with have
the company of each other you know
that's what the gathering is all about
that's why they have their own
mini gatherings you know where they'd
have like a barbecue
or something and some park somewhere we
ain't nowhere near it
and they would they would get together
50 or 100 of them or whatever
and just hang out for the day because
they love each other's company man it's
it really means a lot to them
to be together you know and and what
what it's come down to after all these
years is
sort of like we've been given the role
to organize
these events
we're just a soundtrack you know what
i'm saying to this wonderful [ __ ]
thing that's happening you know this
movement this this underground
movement you know and of course people
always
guess what they don't understand you
know and so people say oh man whatever
the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is that juggalo [ __ ]
you know
they talk [ __ ] about they don't
understand it so they talk [ __ ] about it
but it's actually a very [ __ ]
beautiful thing people have found their
wife or their husband
at these events people that found their
best friends and
you know it's changed people's lives and
it's not
the music that's done it it's it's the
juggalos that did it it's the
company you know i think i think that's
what for some reason
we've been given the role to provide the
music you know and it's just it's an
unbelievable honor man it's cool it's
mind-boggling to try to wrap your
head around it you know i don't know why
we got so fortunate
speaking of uh providing the music
you said that uh the hatchet man
started out as the logo for your record
label
and that's a big [ __ ] deal
when like when a band
uh owns their own music right so when
you say like your record label that
means
you own all of your own publishing music
rights
yeah well you know we didn't we didn't
wait around to try to get signed you
know what i mean like a lot of bands
they'll they'll yeah it's kind of like
it's catch 22 because
if you want to make it big you got to be
signed to a label right if you want to
make money
you got to own your own music so it's
like you're [ __ ] if you do
you're [ __ ] if you don't because if
you sign the label yeah you might blow
up
but then the labels got you for like a
five album deal before you get paid [ __ ]
and like and and if you put out your own
music on your own label yeah you own
your own
music you own the rights but nobody's
[ __ ] listening to it because nobody
knows about you because you don't have
the backing of the label
so very few artists have been able to do
that i mean what comes to mind is
is uh master p was like the initial
[ __ ] like he owned his own music
ah whether cash money [ __ ] birdman
like they own their own music
i can't think of a lot of others you
know but you know what though things are
changing now though
like like now there's almost [ __ ] man
things have changed so much recently
over the last
[ __ ] 20 years in the in the music
business that there's almost no
no need for a major label anymore i mean
you can
you know put something interesting out
together as a poor video
and slap it on youtube and blow the [ __ ]
up all by yourself you know i
put it on itunes and putting on all the
streaming out outlets
and you don't really need a record label
for [ __ ]
i mean today you can do it yourself it's
so
accessible the industry is so it's it's
like it's almost
it's almost foolish to sign a major
label yeah i mean you know because you
got to give more than just
um you got to get what they call a 360
deal now which is you got to get
your touring rights all kinds of [ __ ]
man merchandise money everything you
know and it's like [ __ ] man
because um you know the record labels
are going to get paid one way or another
you know if they can't get paid selling
cds
they're going to get paid selling your
t-shirts or whatever you know
and you're saying yeah i mean the number
of artists that are blowing up on their
own
doing it on their own is just it's like
feels like it feels like it's half the
industry you know and that's awesome
that's the [ __ ] man
you know like i look at the all these
artists that are like
huge pop stars today they came up on
their own
they were famous before they signed a
record deal right justin bieber's the
perfect example
exactly exactly there's i mean there's a
ton of them now
and it's it's the [ __ ] man it's like
it's almost
obsolete like record labels and even
studios even recording studios
they're almost no need for them anymore
because everything you need is in a
laptop
like like you used to pay you know 75
bucks an hour for studio
and for what i mean everything you need
now
it comes i mean my daughter can make a
beat on her phone
and it's yeah you know and she don't
have to even buy a special app for it
it just comes in the phone like that you
know what i mean it's like
things are so different now that like
you can you can
get a microphone plug it into your
laptop get that
situation where they got the sound proof
around the microphone
and stick your headphones on and record
right there there's no need for a studio
there's literally like i heard uh one of
the biggest artists today
cat our doji cat recorded all her hits
in her bedroom
with her brother you know these are
songs going platinum on the radio
and she did them in her bedroom you know
with her brother
that's [ __ ] awesome man that's where
music should be done you know
yeah i think billy eilish is a similar
story like one of her hits she made like
in a hotel room
just oh yeah supporting with your
brother too there's no re there's no
reason
to go out and spend all that money on a
big recording studio
i mean i record in a studio but it's my
studio
and it's just because i'm used to being
in a in a room that looks like that you
know what i mean
but [ __ ] man i mean like there's there's
i tell
artists that are starting out today all
you need is a good
laptop that's your record label that's
your management
that's your studio that's your
everything you know what i mean
right on your laptop you know what i
mean you can do it all yourself man
it's not even hard to find out how to do
it either you know
it's it's really it's it's the lanes
there used to be
secret roads up the up the mountain as
we put it
but now they're like wide avenues like a
lot of the industries
is going up those avenues you know doing
it themselves the
the dyi is everything now it's it's way
bigger than it was when we started out
you know
for sure how many icp albums are there
at this point
[ __ ] gang loads man probably
yeah that's great
actual albums like of of all new music
you know
um [ __ ] man how many fish albums are
there you know it's just
how many fish are there exactly um i
would say
20 probably 25.
that's since 94. then then there's eps
you know
a bunch of eps out and uh um collection
like like um there's a ton of like
singles and one-offs and
and then albums compilations of rare
one-offs and [ __ ] like that there's five
hours
freshness one through volume one through
five and
and i think it may be up to six now and
[ __ ] just crazy amounts of music out you
know what i mean
lots of music out man i i hope one day
when we're dead
there's [ __ ] conventions of our [ __ ]
and everything i'm sure they
will man i'm sure i would be surprised
if they didn't already have that
well you know maybe on a small level you
know what i mean but
that that that'd be [ __ ] incredible
man you know i guess everybody
just wants to be remembered you know
like you want to make your mark
sort i think that's like i don't really
i think about it a lot more than i
should probably but
it seems to be the goal in life right is
is like make your mark
you know what i mean here's the thing
dude like without getting too deep into
it
i think that uh as human beings we're in
a [ __ ]
real jam because we got one instinct
and that is to survive and we have one
guarantee
which is we're not gonna [ __ ] survive
so the one [ __ ] thing we care about
is the
one [ __ ] it's like wait what our [ __ ]
whole existence is a prank on us
that sucks so bad like every instinct is
to not
die and we have to go through life
knowing that we're gonna [ __ ] die
we're just barreling towards the one
[ __ ] thing that we're most afraid of
and we gotta we gotta wrap our head
around that one way or another
so there's three ways people do it they
have kids so they can say oh when i die
you know i reproduce so i got my family
lineage you know like how part of me
lives on
and then the other way is that people if
they turn to religion man that's why
religion's so [ __ ] popular because it
promises that it's okay that you're
gonna die because you can go to heaven
and that's not me either then the third
way is i'm going to leave some [ __ ]
behind i might be gone but the [ __ ] i
leave behind is going to be forever
and uh yeah you and i fall into that
category very clearly
you want to leave your mark you want you
want to be remembered for some reason
but it doesn't really matter when you're
dead
yeah that's the funny thing too it's not
going to matter but but it does now
dude that's why the [ __ ] cavemen in
the caves were drawing [ __ ] stick
figures because they knew
that they're going gonna be dead as [ __ ]
but they're like damn this stick
figure's gonna be here forever
yeah i'm gonna tip this into this rock
and it'll be here forever
yeah dude who did it i did it
[ __ ] you know
you guys are leaving behind not just
music like a culture like a whole
it's insane you guys are in the books of
history with the only [ __ ]
registered gang dude i'm joining man i
want to go to the [ __ ] tattoo
i became a tattoo artist man so i don't
know if i'm going to give myself my
[ __ ] hatchet man
yeah we could stop by violent jays on
the route and are you you're in detroit
right
yeah yeah so
one thing we thought was uh pretty
interesting [ __ ] scott rolled up he
goes man dude
you got lucky man like these guys don't
[ __ ] around like
you know they they beef with everybody
they're [ __ ] they scrap with
[ __ ] like but i felt like you
know seeing the interviews back in
0.40908
like you were down for that but it seems
like now you're kind of just super
mellow
and you want to just [ __ ] chill it's
hard not to be because
man i mean like okay like we used to
proudly call ourselves the most hated
man in the world you know that's how we
felt
it seemed true almost you know we're the
most hated band in the world like
like i mean i could give a million
examples you know what i mean
from being usa today's worst band of all
time
making that list number one several
times you know what i mean
i mean the magazines that have that have
dissed us is [ __ ] endless
but um it don't seem like that no more
it seems like every time there's a story
about us now they're saying something
good you know
like they're saying something nice about
us and it's it's it's hard to
have that chip on your shoulder anymore
because so much is
we've got so much to be proud of and and
to be happy about
and we really we receive so much love
how we gonna go around being pissed off
man
and be real at the same time you know
what i mean like look at look at how
fortunate we are man i mean like
my i got my kids college paid for man
you know what i mean
i'm doing something i would do for
[ __ ] free i would pay to do this man
i would i
i did pay to do this for years you know
and um to actually make money doing
something we love i mean
how are we gonna how are we gonna go
around being bitter and salty
with when we're that fortunate you know
what i mean like looking at other people
working these shitty [ __ ] jobs man
and obviously hate
you know it's like i think we're
extremely fortunate man
and and and it's hard to walk around
being
mad at the world when when you had that
kind of fortune man you know what i mean
but for the sake of entertainment but
you know just to
for the sake of entertaining the
listeners let's talk about when you were
like salty like right like why did you
like do
am i corrected you like just gotten a
feud
a rap beef with eminem yeah
yeah we got we it's all love now of
course you know what i mean but yeah we
got into it and
it was more of a um it was an
ugly ugly battle you know but that's
because we're both from detroit and our
camps were fighting
it wasn't us and eminem scrapping
somewhere you know what i mean it was
our camps
fighting each other and that was that
wasn't good man that was bad you know
what i mean
it was like you know what i mean those
guys would be at somewhere and we would
be somewhere and it would just be a
[ __ ]
war jumping off on the street you know
and it wouldn't even involve
him or us at all you know what i mean
and that was just [ __ ] up man for a
long
time you know what i mean that was an
ugly fight man and before he passed away
uh proof um who was eminem's
right-hand man and and of course he's a
lot more than that
especially here in detroit man he's like
um he's like a godfather rap here in
detroit he's like a um
legend you know what i mean um but proof
um was on a mission it seemed
to squash a lot of the beefs
eminem had you know what i mean yeah in
this
like about the right about the year he
died
proof was doing this and and he reached
out to us
and we had like a bowling match it was
us versus d12
and like a bowling match you know that
was [ __ ] awesome
i was so proud that he included us
because
like i said we were the most hated band
it was like i'll [ __ ] them they don't
count you know
like if you if you were naming off
groups music
um that was successful from detroit you
could name off all kind of people
and then somebody'd say what about icp
oh man [ __ ] them they don't count you
know what i mean
it was always like that so when proof
included us
to squash the beef and he he came to our
office
and um and like he he jumped on a song
with one of our groups
and um he gave us a shout out in his
verse and [ __ ] it was just
it meant a lot to us man i mean it
really meant a lot you know what i mean
and um he ended up being killed
just months later and i wanted to go to
the funeral you know but but um
i didn't know if eminem himself
knew about what proof was doing to the
extent
right and i didn't want to show up at
bruce funeral and that ma'am and mcs
they were like what the [ __ ] are they
doing here you know what i mean
i didn't want to take the chance of
something like that happening
you know what i mean um because i know
he was so much closer to proof
i mean so much incredibly closer you
know it just
it was it was a [ __ ] up time you know
what i mean um but uh
yeah you know that was an ugly war for a
long time man
say top three other beefs
[Laughter]
we didn't really have a gang of beefs
like that you know what i mean i mean
we we would get arrested for fighting
you know people would just come up
talking [ __ ] you know i mean like
i know you've you've had to have had it
steve oh man you've had that people just
come up say
you ain't all that steve oh just for no
reason you're like what the [ __ ]
it's about you know sure i know people
probably go up to tyson
and say yeah you hit that hard you know
what i mean
yeah if you fight back is a lawsuit and
they get money exactly
exactly you know i mean i think that's
why like all celebrities
sometimes have security you know because
people
just get you know they just they just
see you there and they get
you might be sitting in a strip club and
they just get salty you're there you
know
yeah [ __ ] over there shining i
hate them you know
you know dissing you for no [ __ ]
reason you know what i mean so we'd get
arrested for fighting here and there but
we didn't go around like just fighting
everybody you know for no reason we
always had
a legit reason i thought you know what i
mean i get that impression
i was watching a clip of uh you guys on
howard stern when sharon osborne and you
guys were kind of like
there was some confrontation there but i
love going back to like you guys being
so independent
you were like what are you even gonna do
to us like we're untouchable like what
you're gonna take me off the radio like
i'm not on the radio like
i got my own label like there's you were
kind of like it was a good example to
show like
the way you guys went even though it's
so hard you sort of
you're like invincible though true
though it was true she was like a
a giant in the industry you know but we
were we were like out of the industry
you know we were in the streets
we were in in the industry we were in
the streets you know
it didn't really matter all the
connections she had you know what i mean
we were like whatever [ __ ] you you know
and uh i remember she said um um
she said your next album i'll bet you
right now
i don't remember what she bet but she
said um your next album won't sell 50
000 copies we were like [ __ ] you know
what i mean and and
i always wanted to go back on there
because she she was the one that made
that bet you know what i mean
our next album sold that and our next
four sold that you know what i mean so
she lost that [ __ ] bet and i want
that money dedicated
to a [ __ ] charity in our name you
know what i mean because she lost that
[ __ ] bed
and she was the one that made it on that
show you know what i mean so
hey uh so i'm so fascinated with the
we've had a guest on here that's been
interviewed by this person but i saw
that you guys got interviewed
and i'm wondering oh is this the person
who digs up like yeah
when you guys did the interview with
nardwar oh yeah
did you ever find out how he knows that
[ __ ] because when he's like hey
so you date girls at kinko's like who
would have [ __ ] told them
in your camp some of the stuff that like
nobody knows
i suppose he could have just read our
book or or something but i'm gonna tell
you something i don't wanna i don't
wanna say anything bad about
but not not the wire but um i got to
tell you something man
this sucks too he gives you all this
bottom ass [ __ ] like he
like he gives you all these rare
mix-a-lot
albums and stuff that he's yeah yeah
you're like whoa where did you find this
you know it gives you all that stuff
you're like
[ __ ] yeah you know i remember he gave us
a smiley album
who's a local detroit rapper we used to
be fans of when we were kids
and he had some smiley vinyl we were
like oh my god you know he gave it to us
we're like hell yeah
and then after the interview he takes it
back man
what do you mean he's like yeah i need
that back we're like now
the key chain that he gave you guys
first off took everything back
you guys were so
it's like that mtv show buzzkill yeah
dude and this guy's totally open [ __ ] in
the world man we were so grateful you
know and then he's like all right now
we're done really i didn't know that
because he gives albums to everybody
dude you have told me about that [ __ ]
guy
like 30 times yeah you're so stoked
i want dude now we gotta ask all the did
he like whitney coming
he did whitney cummings and he'll say
something we gotta ask her like
i was dying because we had whitney
cummings on and he would say something
to her
and she's like nobody ever knew that
about me like
it's something that a waiter said to her
in seventh grade that she told
like so i was always curious if you guys
ever found out how the [ __ ] does he know
that kind of [ __ ] he's like i don't give
a [ __ ] how he knew him [ __ ] that guy
it's cool how he does that though that's
a cool thing like he looks seen as like
really rare things about a person you
know that's makes it interesting you
know
every time he interviews somebody he's
always like flipping their wig with some
[ __ ] that they don't
expect him to say you know what i mean
right yeah well it's always like
it's always mind-blowing stuff and so i
was just curious because he kind of
he was saying some stuff to you and you
were like what the [ __ ] like
you're flipping my with my my wig back
dude like what do you
what's going on here he's good with that
[ __ ] man but you know
i think most most of what he said to us
um was i'm pretty sure most of it was in
the book
in the book i wrote i wrote a book
probably about 10 years ago i think most
of it was in there
or some of it wasn't you know he's just
good like that i don't know it's a
mystery man
i think that it sounds like from all the
time scott brought him up that his
his stick is like you know
some next level [ __ ] that's not like
like i'm gonna guess from what i
understand that
some [ __ ] wasn't in the book
yeah he's good with that he's got he's
got some um spies working for him or
something to
get dig into some some secretive [ __ ]
about people i don't know what he's
doing what he's doing
he's got a lot of unexpected questions
including can i have that back
now that's the only question i remember
we had handfuls of [ __ ] we're like hell
yeah that's the dopest interview we ever
did
yeah so speaking of handfuls of [ __ ] and
like i mean that's what i remember
again back in the day of 2004 i remember
like
being told these guys [ __ ] sell
merch you know like merch like they're
the [ __ ]
kings of just loyal fan base that buys
all their [ __ ]
so is that still like still going down
and like we ask everybody but who
fulfills
your merch orders do you have your own
we have used to be we used to do it all
out of a warehouse you know what i mean
and have uh guys working there that
would you know we used to do it the
old-school way
order five double xl five
triple xl five four xl you know
and then wait for him to sell but now
everything's done made to order you know
what i mean like
okay yeah so so we have companies that
we
we certain things have been um certain
things have been licensed off to this
company and other things have been
licensed off to this company you know
but you know what really [ __ ] hurt us
big time man as far as merch sales
we used to be among hot topics
top 10 all the way up until
the actual year the fbi
released that [ __ ] um gang list man
and then our merchandise became gang
apparel
and and and hot topic took it right out
of the [ __ ] store
and we even did a concert for them at
their warehouse
we did a concert we were so tight with
hot topic
we did a concert for their employees at
their warehouse somewhere in california
we
never did no [ __ ] like that we did it
for them because we had such a great
relationship
and it was like two years later that
list came out
and we were took it out of the store
forever and we still ain't in there man
did did being on that list help in any
way
[ __ ] no
um all we could do was think um
we wanted to at the end of the day
all we wanted to do was tell everybody
we're not
okay with it because if you if you don't
say that you might as well be okay with
it right
like when the gang list came out we
wanted everybody to know
[ __ ] that we ain't a gang all right and
the only way we could say that
the loudest way we could say that was to
do a march on washington
and so we did that you know and we did a
march on washington and
it was [ __ ] greatest thing in my life
man that whole year was the most
stressful year of my life we did
we announced it a year in advance and we
didn't know
man we didn't know if five people were
coming we had no
way of knowing if anybody was actually
coming there's not
tickets sold for it we had no idea you
know and we found out
how expensive hotels are in dc and [ __ ]
and we're like oh man it was just
looking so grim
and um the whole year it was it was just
a very stressful [ __ ] year
but the day the day of the march came
first the week of the march came
and we did mad amounts of press and
every everything oppressed we did
like had our side had our back and it
was unbelievable we couldn't believe it
it was
it was the greatest thing in the [ __ ]
greatest endeavor we ever did
and then when we came to the march there
was like about 5 000 people at the march
and that was best day of my life best
day of our of our career
you know i mean you know we couldn't we
could have had
fifty thousand or a hundred thousand
five thousand was
five thousand more than we expected man
that was the [ __ ] greatest
day of our career man and it was so
wonderful
actually doing the march you know it was
so [ __ ]
what a great [ __ ] awesome day that
was man
and and uh that happened in 2017
and um it was just it was just the
greatest man
it was the greatest event i've ever been
a part of man it was
it was the most [ __ ] man i don't even
have words for it man it was
i can't even express what it meant to us
man it was it was [ __ ]
beautiful hey when uh when i saw that uh
you know violent jade talks about his
beef with stevo
uh video right away i wanted to reach
out to you
and i was looking on instagram to try to
find
like and i couldn't tell like it didn't
seem like uh
like i couldn't identify a distinct
violent j
instagram page do you have your own one
yeah i got i got
uh my my instagram what's my instagram
yeah violet j dot icp
yeah all right dude boom got you on
there what a cool dude
yeah man i got a dude you have so much
uh
so much gratitude so much humility
it's like uh you know i think a lot of
people might be surprised
like god dude the icp guy man like the
[ __ ] good dude
you know it's uh brother listen i want
to say something real quick your
instagram is the [ __ ] brother i love
following you man
ah man work hard on your instagram you
always got some sweet ass picture
dope as [ __ ] i mean you always i'm
always like damn he's got the best
instagram man
oh man that means the world to me
brother i appreciate it dude and uh
he's got like an outrageous picture
something on there it's like crazy as
hell it's like i love vlogging on you
bro man
it's dope man you do a great job with
that man thank you for that man i wasn't
sure what uh
what your account was man but uh but now
now i asked you and i just hit follow on
you so
if you ever wanna like [ __ ] holler at
me if there's anything i can do
for you man just shoot that dm it'll go
right like uh
you know it'll show up like yo you got a
message you know i know
i would love to do something to uh
collaborate with you to
you know get behind you to [ __ ] we'd
love to have you at the gathering man
have you hoped the main stages together
and that would rock man
all right
wait before we wrap up i do have a
question i have one more question all
right
uh so i went to music business school
and they talk about you guys like these
guys did it full independent
um but there's like this legend that
people talk about where they say icp
picked just a random town on the map and
it just ended up being this one random
place in texas and they went there
and just flooded it with posters and
flyers and to this day they have a real
big following in this one random town in
texas is there truth to that
yeah we we um because we um
we had detroit you know it it seemed
like
we were just a local thing because we
were selling so many records in detroit
that we are trying to get a record deal
this is back in like 1995.
we were trying to get a record deal so
um jive records
they're not even around anymore it's
hard to believe there was such a huge
label
uh jive records came and signed us and
um
and um but they only put us out like in
in
michigan basically we you know we're
selling like 80 000
um units in in the detroit
area and so basically they signed us and
just
were selling that and taking all the
money you know what i mean but they
weren't really working the record
anywhere else
so we threw a dart at a a map of america
and it landed on dallas texas and we we
we [ __ ] we took we took
we bought three vans and we wrapped them
with our
our album cover and all that and we put
fat rims on it and
put sounds in them and we drove the vans
to to and we got samplers of the album
we bought
[ __ ] 100 000 samplers and flyers and
posters
and we basically moved to dallas and we
just
concentrated on dallas texas like
everything we had
we just pumped dallas texas every day at
three o'clock
those vans would be at three different
high schools in the dallas area
handing out samplers to all the kids
coming out you know
just handing out free samplers everybody
you know and uh
we go to all the record stores we go
down to deep ellum where all the
clubs were at night we'd hand out
samplers everybody
going to all the bars and clubs and you
know and um
man next thing you know we had two
markets we had detroit and dallas you
know it worked
and it was it was our way of proven to
the label
man all you gotta do is work it you know
it's not they thought it was like a
local thing the clown [ __ ] they didn't
understand they thought
uh some weird detroit thing because if
you look at the history of detroit
kiss detroit was one of the first cities
they were successful in
you know alice cooper's from detroit
with his
crazy paint and all that i mean
detroit's always been like a
a weird place when it comes to painted
faces and showmanship you know what i
mean
and um so i think in the beginning the
record label thought we were just
a detroit thing happening you know but
we wanted to prove we could we could hit
anywhere
if if the attention was given to it you
know and uh we did we proved it you know
but
we didn't really care at that point we
had we had started to build
our foundation ourselves and pretty much
by the time we ended up signing the
record deal
we wish we hadn't you know what i mean
as we built our label up so big
there wasn't much they could do for us
anyway you know what i mean
[ __ ] yeah start to answer your question
sounds like it's a hundred percent true
sounds like yeah i was always curious
man i'm so glad to hear it from you
that's awesome
yeah that's dope man that they did they
talked about us in that in that class
man that's the
way where was the school paul i went to
full sail
university in orlando florida and it's i
was like in a music business program
but yeah they were you know in like it
was a lot of this like you don't really
need a label necessarily and you can do
it independent and
the band they really point to is icp and
like uh
everything that they did to just
cultivate their own audience and even
this whole like
you don't need a million fans they're
like if you have a thousand fans
that are willing to spend a hundred
dollars on you either music shirt
cd a year that's 100 grand a year like
build from that you know and like you
don't need
mass appeal you just need people that
really
[ __ ] with you man my advice to everybody
is don't don't wait for somebody to come
save you don't wait for somebody to come
lift you up and take you on tour
something start building
you start walking up the mountain but
it's the only way you're going to
guarantee to get up that mountain
start walking yeah it's 50 000 miles
yeah it's gonna take years but you know
what if you want to guarantee you're
going to get up that [ __ ]
start walking you know i mean just it's
part of the fun is is climbing the
mountain
i mean a lot of times people people
don't realize that that's the best
of the adventure a lot of times when you
get to where you're trying to go
it's not what you thought it would be
like so you realize
the real joy was
climbing the mountain the whole time
that's when you you gain a little bit of
traction you're like hell yeah
it's so rewarding you know you keep
getting
you keep coming farther and farther it's
rewarded after reward after reward
it's very enlightening you know to do it
yourself
and guarantee you're gonna eventually
get up that mountain
because if you sit and wait you might
wait your whole life away and it never
happens man you know what i mean
it's damn right start walking up that
mountain man that's what i tell
everybody man
yeah it looks like a forever journey but
it's rewarding you know it's like if
you're trying to lose weight
it's not like you have to weigh 500
pounds
for five years and then one morning you
wake up and you've lost it all you get
to lose weight
all along the way you know what i mean
so it's the [ __ ] you know
i mean start losing it you know what i
mean don't don't just wait for somebody
to come along and take it off you you
know what i mean
oh man what a great [ __ ] message
i uh i'm so glad we did this man and
uh i really like i said before man i
wish i would have
thought to reach out to you i [ __ ]
didn't i'm sorry for that
and uh you know i i wanna
i officially acknowledge i was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to you dude you didn't deserve
that
you you're the man man you got nothing
but my respect man to the fullest
brother i
i respect you i have respected you man i
respect you after i read your book
and i and i expect you more now man
thank you brother thank you for inviting
me on
and thank you and um man i i appreciate
it so much brother dude
i respect you like more than ever man
i'm from [ __ ] man we
i think everybody that watch this that
listened to this
just [ __ ] fell in love with you man
like uh really an honor brother thank
you
thank you brother that's a wonderful dog
too what kind of dog is that
i found her in the streets of peru she's
a south american
really yeah south american street dog
that's her um
that's her breed yeah that's awesome man
that is awesome
hell yeah dude but hey hit me up anytime
man
for sure brother you guys be cool man
thank you
man i gotta say that was genuinely
healing for me man
you know i wish i would have had that
conversation years ago but hey better
late than never
and what what can i say man do you guys
just stick around to the very
end i love you you want to know
something ironic okay this warehouse
that i'm in tight box packing the
immediate
next door neighbor it's this [ __ ]
dance studio
that just blares music all day long
we're trying to record stuff in here
it's a nightmare
i get so mad i'm like ah then it occurs
to me
the irony of me having a [ __ ]
neighbor that won't shut the [ __ ] up
it's pretty rich in any case thank you
guys now it's time to skateboard